we're coming to you straight out of
riverdale welcome back the things fans
have you ever been watching riverdale
and wish that you could somehow watch
your favorite actors
all day well you kind of can although
there's no doubt cole
lily and kj were literally made to play
jughead betty and archie they've also
taken on some pretty
awesome roles outside of riverdale
luckily we are here to give you the down
low on all their projects
clear your schedule because you'll be
wanting to add all these movies and
series to your binge list asap
cole sprouse has been there for you
since the very beginning
one of the first gigs was on a little
90s sitcom you might know of
as friends he was ross geller's son
throughout the entire series
so if you're ever in a nostalgic mood
and find yourself missing cole
you can always turn on one of the many
episodes he was in and laugh along
riverdale's success has given its cast
major hollywood opportunities
especially lily reinhardt she starred in
the 2019 film hustlers alongside some
huge celebrities
she worked with jlo and cardi b hashtag
goals
but beware if you ever decide to watch
hustlers the content is a little more
mature than betty's high school antics
let's just say there's a lot of dancing
and a lot of polls involved
lily isn't the only one who's worked
with big time celebrities
well yes cole arguably got to work with
some big names during his time on
friends he also worked with adam sandler
in the huge 90s blockbuster movie big
daddy
he played julian with his twin brother
imagine having adam sandler as your
on-screen dad
law and order special victims unit
wasn't lily reinhardt's first gig but it
was definitely the role that launched
her into mainstream tv
she guest starred in the episode lost
traveler back in 2011
which means she was just 15 years old
that's a huge accomplishment
and just six years later she was killing
it as betty on our favorite show
talk about a turn of events if you
thought jughead was romantic and deep
just wait until you watch cole do his
thing in this 2019 film
five feet apart his character will
acting and
truly unfair puppy dog face will have
you sobbing
in seconds it's a completely different
vibe from his usual mysterious brooding
on riverdale but if you're into love
stories and romance you will
not be disappointed make sure to have
tissues handy
okay it's safe to say that madelaine
pecha's cheryl blossom can definitely
get spooky
especially in season one if you're
someone who loves her creepy side then
you have to watch the horror film she
just released
the movie is called sightless and in it
madelaine plays a patient who is
recovering from going blind
but she's still being stalked by the
person who made her blind in the first
place
honestly we can definitely see riverdale
taking on this storyline
speaking of creepy camila mendes also
took on the thriller and
horror world in her netflix film
dangerous lies
she plays the main character caregiver
katie who inherits a patient's estate
much to the disappointment of the family
things get dark after his death and the
film will definitely remind you of the
classic clue storyline
let us know if you figure out the
mystery before the end of the movie
the kissing booth part 1 and 2 have been
wildly huge movies for netflix in the
past two years
we are pretty sure you're familiar with
the angsty romance between elle and noah
but did you know a riverdale actor you
know and love is also a pretty important
character in those films
molly ringwald also known as mary
andrews plays mrs flynn in the films
did you recognize her cole sprouse has
been living
the sweet life since he was only 12
years old before riverdale the world new
cole sprouse is one of the disney
channel's biggest stars
he played cody martin on the suite life
of zack and cody again
alongside his brother dylan the show was
so big it landed a spin-off
sweet life on deck and even got a disney
channel movie
if you want to see cole play a character
that's completely different from jughead
this sitcom is it if there's one thing
gen z
is passionate about it's fighting for
what they believe in and this book to
movie adaptation
is the perfect example the hate u give
film even included one of riverdale's
biggest stars
kj appa he plays chris the leading
lady's love interest
things get real serious in this film so
it's definitely a perfect watch if you
want to catch kj
in a new light riverdale has added so
much to people's lives when it comes to
the entertainment industry but the
series has also done wonders for their
actors careers
charles melton also known as reggie
mantle may not have had a huge role on
riverdale but he still landed the
blockbuster film
bad boys for life he played the
character rafe and worked alongside big
names like will smith vanessa hudgins
and martin lawrence
you can also find madelaine in the 2017
horror movie
polaroid she's one of the film's main
characters and let's just say cameras
are definitely not her friend in this
film
okay we're starting to notice a trend
madeleine is she low-key
obsessed with horror movies she
definitely has a knack for bringing
creepy characters to life so we are not
complaining
if you've been wondering if kj appa is
actually singing and playing the guitar
during archie andrews musical scenes
the movie i still believe is your answer
kj isn't just an iconic actor his
musical talent definitely belongs on the
main stage also
in the 2020 film he actually portrayed a
real-life music star
jeremy camp country star shania twain
was even in the movie
tony topez may have started as a side
character on riverdale but her actress
vanessa morgan definitely proved herself
now she gets plenty more screen time and
we are here for it
but aside from riverdale she also got to
show off her skills in the chanera
chronicles series
she played one of the main characters
lyria on the show's second season
we definitely recommend the series if
you're into the whole supernatural side
of riverdale
luke perry was iconic before and during
his time on riverdale
talking about this actor is a little
bittersweet as fans had to say goodbye
to luke when he passed away in early
2019 but all the more reason to
appreciate all the masterpieces he gave
to us while he was here
his last film appearance was actually a
cameo in the oscar-winning movie once
upon a time in hollywood that also stars
brad pitt and leonardo dicaprio
riverdale and the shannara chronicles
might be vanessa morgan's most recent
huge hits
but back in 2014 she landed the role of
bird on the major mtv show
finding carter so riverdale definitely
wasn't vanessa's first rodeo with teen
dramas
practice makes perfect right yeah
this one is for all our fellow 80s
lovers out there if you're ever in the
mood to hit that nostalgia button you
can press play on the breakfast club
that stars molly ringwald not to mention
her other 80s hits like 16 candles and
pretty in pink
if you're looking for something more
recent with molly ringwald you can also
watch her 2018 movie
all these small moments she shows off
just how good she is at drama in this
one
just like how young adults fill their
days watching teen dramas now
people in the 90s did the same before
there was riverdale there was beverly
hills 90210
one of the biggest teen shows of them
all it also happened to star
luke perry by the time he was on
riverdale he was a veteran when it came
to portraying the perfect teen drama
character
nostalgia is calling it wants you to
watch all 10 seasons
before ross butler could be reggie
mantle he was actually a disney actor
and worked alongside one of the biggest
stars to come from disney
zendaya he was featured on casey
undercover as brett willis
next time you're in the disney mood turn
on the series and try to spot him
after landing roles on shows like
riverdale and 13 reasons why
he also scored a part in the movie
shazam as part of the dc superhero
universe
superhero eugene to the rescue it's safe
to say that even if riverdale ended
tomorrow we would have tons of series
and films to keep up with our favorite
actors
we can't wait to see what else these
icons release in the coming years
let us know what shows or movies from
this video you'll be adding to your
binge list in the comment section below
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up and hit that subscribe button
catch you in riverdale